well folks rudy giuliani now admits
that he did the massive dumps um it the
the jokes write themselves at this point
in time like how can i add anything and
i'll be completely upfront
this is just
comedic insanity period
there is no
credibility to rudy giuliani at this
point
there is no i mean the guy is as
backwards as anybody we've seen
affiliated with american politics in the
last many years
rudy giuliani went on newsmax
and he told eric balling
he did the big dump and for those of you
who have been following this entire
massive dumps storyline for the last
couple years this will be particularly
odd check this out so here they're
saying things like there's going to be a
big dump
and there was a big dump
i put out the big dump to the new york
post
oh guys i i
i can't do it any longer i just can't do
it if you um
if they if they wanted to joke about the
whole dumps thing and at snl's writing
room
someone came up with this fake giuliani
saying this
they would be looked at like what what
are you 10 years old what are you
talking about a dump what do you mean it
doesn't make any sense nobody would
believe that now rudy's also going to go
out and talk about a big dump
and then here it is now as a reminder
this all goes back to this infamous
um
historic moment historic moment in
american political history and what
happened if you watched the election i
was called by the biggest people
uh saying congratulations political
people congratulations sir you just won
the election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps right they call them dumps big
massive dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania
and and maria vardaromo's eyeglass
adjustment right when trump says massive
dumps is still just i mean absolutely
perfect so what is this all about you i
know many of you are going to be shocked
by this all of this stuff that rudy's
saying the dumps and everything
the context is the hunter biden laptop
story
i know it's it's unbelievable but
they're still talking about hunter
biden's laptop so here is a little more
of the rudy interview
it's actually interesting to in the
middle of unprecedented legal problems
for donald trump
they're talking about the hunter biden
laptop mr mayor since when does the fbi
tell a private company like facebook
what to publish and what not to publish
i mean
also any questions private company
about national security information
that's a good point
wow i mean when did they when did when
did when did they do that
that's a very very good point right
national security whether or not there's
a russian you know that happens to be
that happens to be about the time that i
was communicating with john mack isis
and the fbi had seized a year earlier
my my uh icloud account
so here they're saying things like
there's going to be a big dump
and there was a big dump yeah i put out
the big dump to the new york post right
but that was a three-week period in
which
i was communicating with bob costello
and john mack isaacs we were going back
and forth
imagine trying to follow this and we
were doing our own due diligence to make
sure
that what he had was legitimate yeah and
then there was a big dump
and he
censored it
and you know what that indicates the
government was part of that yeah that
makes all this first amendment stuff
very different one of the ways they get
out of the first amendment is they say
these are private companies but the men
of the government's conspiring like that
it's the government violating
first amendment rights amazing amazing
the fbi reaches out to zuckerberg and
and and facebook goes ahead and
throttles back the story twitter twitter
went even further and just completely
pulled the story you know
it's scary devine called me before and
corrected that oh she said that facebook
was the first twitter followed facebook
yeah and but between my friends
twitter went a little bit mr mayor
always good having you on uh we'll talk
to you all right so they're not really
understanding each other but what's
clear is that
rudy was the source of the dump and i
mean it's this is american politics at
this point in time meanwhile i mean
listen i have to tell you folks
i'm glad to say
that while
the second half of the show
has been me catching you up on
rudy's dumping and trump's lying on a
show no one's heard of hosted by lou
dobbs and it's just it's almost sad like
they're in the toilet for lack of a
better term
it's great that the first half of the
show was
look at joe biden's achievement on
judges
look at how
the approval rating of biden is reacting
to material substantive significant
accomplishments including student loan
student loan debt relief
and the jobs report the inflation
reduction act the pact act and on and on
it's nice that we have some sanity again
and that we have an approval rating at
least within some range responding to
the actions of the president and it's
because i mean
it's they're in the toilet on the right
guys they're in the toilet on the right
and if you think rudy's massive dumps
are disgusting
look at what i'm gonna talk to you about
next